[Music]  I'm gonna go get my hair don't want to  do it that's great  [Laughter]  [Music]  yes so is Justin what is that this chest  that's my mom  Justin Bieber yes nut this chest  no yeah she's not she was ready Chad  sure nut nut this  [Music]  you don't have to do I'm just talking  about straight to get another when I was  going to keep you in the prop give  yourself could you yeah are you so good  my bad I will laugh I won't laugh things  like friendship soon enough oh crap I'm  going to have that test I was here hey  you get it at a having a head head in it  everything does I'm talking to the vein  vein but yeah I got it guys  under on the period and it's just bad  for everyone no more no more no more  let's end girls period I don't it would  bring them over a check say yeah it  could be no pain you my dear hahahahaha  but I'm dead turkey I just thought of  this but that hey Lewbert  [Music]